Speaker 1: OK, as predicted, Donald Trump
was never going to be reinstated to the White
House in August.
There is no mechanism for reinstatement in
the United States Constitution or in the United
States law.
One of the biggest purveyors of these ideas
was Trump sycophant Mike Lyndell, CEO and
founder of the My Pillow Brand, who will also
be holding some kind of what he's calling
a symposium on sometime in early August.
Whether he even knows what symposium means,
I don't know.
But he now has a new date on which he says
Donald Trump will be reinstated.
Michael Andell has set Aug. 13 as the date
where Trump will again become the president
of the United States.
This is the first time he's put a specific
date on this entire thing.
Business Insider reports on it and says My
Pillow CEO Mike Lyndell says he believed former
President Donald Trump would take the impossible
step of being reinstated as president on August
13.
Speaking to Brandon Howes on the conservative
W. VW Broadcast Network on Sunday, Lyndell
said that by that date, Trump's reinstatement
would be the talk of the world.
Donald Trump won, he claimed.
I mean, it's pretty simple.
OK, let's take a look at the video in which
Mike Lyndell says this.
Speaker 2: By the time August 3rd, the morning
of August 13th for the boys, hurry up.
I skipped the selection.
Pull down.
That's right.
The right.
Let's get these communists out.
You know that they're taking over that.
And you'll see when I say that, you know,
and they'll tip off the people that were involved,
I don't know.
Right now, the biggest concern is getting
this done, how Trump won.
I mean, it's pretty simple.
And there were many don't senators do that?
They did, too.
And stuff.
You'll find all that out.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So in addition to this degree of insanity,
Michael Mandel is also claiming that at his
symposium in August, he has voting machines,
that he is going to be holding some kind of
a mock election to reenact how the voting
machines did all the stuff that he claims
that they supposedly did.
So there's there's a few different things
going on here that are worth talking about.
First of all, you know, how many times has
the date changed at this point?
Of course, it's never going to happen.
It's not going to be August 13th.
Couple of weeks ago, Mike Lendell also floated
the idea.
It might be September.
It's never going to happen.
Now, a lot of people come to me and they say,
David, sir, do you think that Mike Lyndell
believes this stuff?
Do you think he actually believes that Donald
Trump genuinely won the election?
Speaker 3: Congratulations, sir.
You just won the election.
Speaker 1: Exactly.
And I think the answer is it doesn't matter
if I had to guess.
I think that Mike Lyndell has the sense that
there was some fraud.
He he believes he doesn't really know whether
it's enough that it would have given the election
to Donald Trump.
But he doesn't care.
And he's making a bunch of money.
He's getting a ton of publicity.
He has all of his conservative friends promoting
his pillow's you know, everybody's got a coupon
code for his pillows and so on and so forth.
I don't think it matters.
I think the important thing is that the big
picture of this is a really, really dangerous
grift because of the fact that their followers
are so gullible.
And if you think that those followers will
ever learn their lesson when August 13th comes
and goes, and lo and behold, Donald Trump
does not become president of the United States,
if you think, then they will finally say,
you know what, guys, this just isn't going
to happen.
It's over.
Look, as an analogy, how many times those
evangelical end of the world apocalypse types
have gotten their dates wrong for the rapture?
We've interviewed some of them on the show.
And every single time that they get the date
wrong, they go back to their followers and
they say there was a miscalculation or some
bad actor got in the way or someone didn't
pray hard enough or whatever the case may
be.
And the exact same thing is what is going
to happen here.
Either it's the deep state that got in the
way, even though it certainly would have happened
if they didn't or whatever the case may be,
that's all going to happen.
The question will be, what is the eventual
grift going to be?
Will it transition into?
Well, the next thing really now is just the
election and it's time to just donate.
Let's donate and we'll we'll win twenty, twenty
two and then it'll become twenty, twenty four.
Is that the grift, is it that some of these
people, like Mike Lyndell might run for something
in some way?
There's been this idea that Mike Lyndell might
run for governor of Minnesota.
I don't know ultimately where the grift is
going to go, but for now it's been very profitable
for Michael and Al and Trump.
Whether he believes it or not, there are reports
Trump does believe it, which is just wacky.
I mean, just cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs.
But the reports that Trump believes, it suggests
to me that he also is seeing this as a reason
to reinvigorate those rallies that he's been
doing and certainly Trump making no friends
with most of the people that were in his administration.
And that's exactly what I want to talk about
next